we're just about done with the month of  februari and that means it's time for  marches free playstation plus games if  you're part of sony's premium service  you already got to vote on one of them  the results are in and broforce beat out  action Hank and assault Android cactus  in last month's community poll that'll  be free on ps4 along with arcade shooter  galaxy ps3 players are getting rescue  game the last guy and twin stick shooter  Super Stardust HD and finally the PS  Vita is getting the fire fighting game  flame over and reality fighters evita  launch title it's a pretty strong lineup  all around these PS Plus games will be  available on march first what do you  think of the lineup you can let me know  on Twitter at chain gun Pope and for all  the PlayStation news you need you're  ready in the right place